- [Man] This Great Big
Story was made possible
by Wells Fargo,
established 1852, re-established 2018.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Almost every
nationality on the planet
is represented in the neighborhoods
of Queens, New York,
which means the streets are lined
with food from around the world.
And if there's one man
who's tried them all,
it's this guy.
Don't be fooled by his slight frame.
He spent the last 20 years unearthing
every hidden gem this
side of the East River.
- We're here in downtown Flushing,
and there's all sorts of things here
including Soy Bean Chen Flower Shop,
which is, of course, a florist.
But you might wonder why
Soy Bean is in the name,
and that's because they sell douhua,
or fresh flower tofu,
wonderful, warm, custardy tofu
right out of this window.
I love this one.
What a great breakfast.
(jazz music)
- Hi, Joe.
- (speaking in foreign language)
Cherry, my sister.
How are you?
- It's good.
- Pata Paplean specializes in Thai
boat noodles, and it's a really funky
Thai bar with this crazy decor,
and the owner's a trip.
Where did you learn how
to make the boat noodles?
- I used to cook with my mom
when I was in Thailand
before I moved to New York.
And then, no other place
that make it in New York.
- Aha.
So it was out of necessity
- That's why I--
Yeah, that's why I try to make it in here.
(jazz music)
- One of my favorite Tibetan restaurants,
Lhasa Fast Food, is nestled
in-between You and Me Wireless
and Little Myanmar Mini Mart,
one of the best places
for Tibetan Beef Momos.
If you think you're lost on the way in,
just look for the prayer flags.
(relaxing music)
What makes the Moma unique is the masala,
or seasoning, that's in there.
So you find Sichuan
peppercorn, ginger, celery,
onion. I like to think of them as
the hamburgers of the Himalayas,
and I mean that as a compliment.
(relaxing music)
The reason that places like this resonate
with me is because
they're not trying to
make it the next it thing,
the next Instagram food.
It's just like,
"Hey, this is what we make back home.
If you like it, too, come on in."
Queens has everything.
Go explore the neighborhood
and find what's out there.
It's super easy, accessible, delicious,
and people are a lot more welcoming
and open than you might think.